As we go to our next game,
The Rejects-Files.
-The hit series from the 1900s,
X-Files, is back on Fox -What?
for a six-episode revival!
And, seriously,
it's (bleep) great.
If you're not watching it,
I don't know why
you don't like good things.
But for those of you
who are too young to remember,
The X-Files was about a team
of FBI agents,
uh, who was partially led by
the guy from Red Shoe Diaries,
who investigated
all the bizarre unsolved cases
the government couldn't crack,
while we all watched 'em
and just waited for them,
"Please, for the love of God,
just do it one time.
One time, one time!"
But clearly its return
to television means
that there are still cases
as yet unsolved.
So, comedians, I would like you
to come up with some new X-Files
paranormal cold cases that
are just waiting to be solved.
And begin. Scott.
Uh, the Trumpacabra, which is
a-a little orange creature
-that eats Mexicans.
-Yes, points.
(cheering and applause)
Points for that. Annabeth.
Are aliens
just really into butt stuff?
Yes, points. Yeah.
They are. Greg Proops.
The mystery of why
David Duchovny looks old
and Gillian Anderson looks
exactly the same.
All right, points.
-Ah. Oh.
-Scott Adsit.
Uh, the recyclable
Twilight Zone episodes.
Aw! They are not recyclable
Twilight Zone episodes!
-That's why it's a mystery!
-They are not at all!
The Twilight Zone
were-were social commentary
-and morality tales! -Oh, and
this is just a bunch of crap?!
-Why are you indicating to her?!
-Me?! Crap?!
-She's on the show!
-I know she's on the show!
-It's her show you're insulting!
-I lo... You insulted the show!
-I don't think so, sir!
-No! Scott, Scott, Scott,
if you watch the tapes back,
the truth is out there!
I never watch this show!
-Uh... -Did you say "points"
after I said that?
-Oh. Points?
-Yeah.
Not like you're gonna see it
later.
(laughter)